Okay, so
I've been stressed because my fucking 8 year old
third grade child got fucking suspended from school.
I was like, you can suspend a fucking third grader?
He's. He's eight.
Fucking eight years old.
Yeah, you can
when you beat the shit out of kids
every fucking time you're in school.
So that had me really fucking stressed.
And this thing.
A lot of people have asked me what this thing was deserving.
It's a wearable heating pad for cramps.
So you turn it on,
turn it on and it's really dope because it gets really hot.
See, it'll vibrate.
I have heard stories of girls that say they put this on,
there's like different settings for the vibrate,
and then there's different temperatures for the heating, 50,
55, and then 60.
And then it.
You could just set it right there where it gets creepy and it helps it.
Some girls have said that they orgasmed from the vibrations,
just sitting there for long enough.